What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
It's time for the first challenge episode of 2020
Let's go!
Okay that's the first one
So the next challenge is to
play with a polaroid picture of yourself
Emil, say cheese!
Okay I think the polaroid pictures are ready
So I'll be playing with this
This looks even more crazy!
These are from a horror film these pictures
If there would be a picture of Ma Long
you would get all the forehands on table
But luckily we have a picture of Otto
so soon it's gonna be mayhem time
That would have been good!
Who is gonna miss: Miikka or Emil?
Emil!
Otto how does it feel that i'm playing with you?
It just hurts to see how bad you play
These are probaly the worst pictures of us ever taken!
30 chops in 40 seconds, let's see if we can do it!
Lets tape these two rackets together
How are you supposed to play with this?
This feels a bit like tennis
I just hope the racket is not gonna come off
That would have been too good to be true!
It's actually good because you have better reach with this one
You don't have to move so much
And I like that!
Well it didn't hit the rubber but still a good shot
Remember to subsribe to our channel here
and watch our previous videos there!
Until next time!